hello everyone I hope you're all having
got wonderful Sunday and yes I have been
trying out the youtube story feature
with the photo and also with one video
and a lot of you were well surprised
that I actually have braces so yeah I I
did have them installed some four months
ago I don't know I thought yeah it's
now's as good a time as any to get it
done but yeah this is a game from the
9th fleet rest titled arena I'm pretty
sure out of the eight that were already
played across someone like six and he
always donated all of the money back to
litoris so they can use the money to
increase the prize fund for the next
leaches arena I think one he didn't play
and the one he played but he left that
half of the tournament so this is the
9th edition it's really a crazy game as
it features not the original bonk cloud
but an improved version of the bond
cloud not even improved but improvised
by Coulson so I hope you enjoy it and
you know it's it's Sunday why not show a
nice crazy game basically a bomb cloud
although it's pointless to use this in a
real game it can be used for a lot of
things it can be used to teach children
how how to defend properly you know
force them to play the bomb cloud and
then if they are playing against the
weaker opponent that their opponent will
just rush and want to crush them and
then you will be able to if you defend
properly you will be able to punish your
opponent for for trying to finish the
game too early or you can use it like
Carlson uses it in online games well to
to kind of make it more fun or also I
don't want to say to him humiliate your
opponents but yeah if you lose against
someone who plays the bomb cloud that's
that's pretty much a humiliation but
that's what the internet is for amongst
other things so let's see how the game
went Carlson has the white pieces and he
opens with c3 he wants to play Queen to
a4 Queen to h4 push the f3 pawn bring
the King over to the d1 and then bring
the Queen over to e1 so basically he
wants to switch places Queen with the
King and as I've caught a glimpse of the
inter of the
dream on Andrew attends a twitch channel
so I'll also put a link to that in the
description below if he uploaded it to
YouTube I think it's like the fourth or
fifth game that he played so if any of
you have the exact time stamp I will
also add that into the description so
please share it if you do have that but
okay d5
grabbing the center Queen to a for
crossing goes for his improvised the
addition of the bonk cloud nice the c6
blocking check we have Queen to h4
Knight to f6 and now f3 and entertain
mentions in in his stream that he heard
that Carson was drinking beer and
playing crazy openings and it's always
interesting every leaches title arena
andrew is really hyped to play against
Carson and he'll wait he he crushes
pretty much everyone but every time he
plays against Carson he's really nervous
and I think that's one of the reasons
and that he loses most of the games
against him because other than that
andrew is pretty much unbeatable but ok
here he doesn't go for for normal
development but he wants the punish
Carson maybe Carson is pre moving maybe
he cross removed King D 1 Andrew knows
what Carson is doing so he gives it a
try also he will get some development in
Carson grabs it we have rook to g8 Queen
back to h4 and now he 5 and Carson goes
for King to d1 so Carson is still
proceeding with his plan he wants to
switch places King to d1 and Queen to e1
Bishop to a5 Andrew simply continues
development he did give up one pawn for
the semi open G file but it's not a
problem
Queen back to e1 and Carlson has well he
didn't even start developing but we
could say that he completed his
development he completed the bone cloud
so the challenge has been completed but
now he also has to play the game and
everything he did so far this is a move
8th he only played c3 d3 and switch to
the king with the Queen so that's quite
a handicap to give your opponent but ok
Queen to d6
Andrew prepares queenside castle we have
d3 now now Carson is ready to play the
game
we have queenside castle Knights to d2
and now comes d4 so of course Carlsen
scheme
in the center not only one but still the
center and then drew wants to bust open
the center to start attacking as he
already has an ice queen queen battery
on the D file so he wouldn't mind
opening up the position the fourth
caution of course wants the D file to
stay closed and now comes a III stifling
crossings position nice to be three and
now comes look to ei eight defending the
e3 pawn g4 and here
Carlson wants Andrew to push beshrew
back to g6 then it'll go maybe h4 maybe
the night is coming to h3 maybe then to
f4 at some point maybe the queen is
coming to g3 to offer a trade of Queens
who knows Carson is trying very hard to
make this whole bonk bonk or the idea
work but Andrew says no no you don't
hear Andrew decide to sacrifice the rook
and go for a mating attack we have rook
captures on g4 f captures on g4 and now
comes Knight captures on g4 Andrews
Bishop from f5 is controlling the C 2
square and then nice 2 F 2 will be
deadly this will be checked the King
will have nowhere to go and cross and
will have to give up his queen and it's
a very interesting moment in the game I
don't know if I mentioned this maybe
some of you are new to this but leaches
titled arena is a bullet tournament so
the the time format is 1 + 0 1 minute
no no seconds increment so really a wild
time format but when every time crossing
plays against Andrew the games are of
very very high quality here an
interesting move would be better to h3
but of course you cannot expect such
moves in a bullet game because now white
could actually afford to give up the
Queen after Queen captures and have to
Bishop captures sorry pawn captures
Bishop captures will check King moves
mb8 or d8 and then after Knight to f3
white will have excellent compensation
for the Queen a nice to rook into pieces
but cousin goes for a different plan
Knight to h3 guarding the f2 square we
have Queen to g6 completely exploiting
Carlson's blunder Knight to h3 is a
losing blunder now there's very little
you can do against the bishop to see -
this will be checkmate as the pawn is
controlling the D 2 square so Carlsen
plays Queen
back to g3 now there's a d1 square is
free for his king
we have Bishop to d6 attacking Carlson's
Queen Queen to h4 and here white andrew
has a completely winning position but
it's hard to find a move in a bullet
game but you are not in a bullet game
you are you know comfortable in your in
your own home I presume checking out
this video so feel free to pause the
video and try to find this crushing idea
Black has in this position so I will
give you a couple of seconds if you want
to do it for those of you who were able
to do it congratulations you have just
defeated the world champion Magnus
Carlsen in a bullet game
so congratulations he really um I'm
having an excellent Sunday and for those
who just want to enjoy the show the
movies actually nice to be for really a
wonderful idea if the straight forward
pawn captures Bishop captures then with
this position being opened up
now this Bishop is slicing all the way
here over the dark squares and there's
no stopping Bishop to c2 so white is
completely lost here and if you don't
capture the night if you just play
something there's not all that much you
can do the Queen has really no squares
if you play something rush up the g2
then Bishop to d3 will be deadly and now
pretty much everything wins for black of
course if you capture then it's straight
straight out checkmate the King moves
Knight the C 2 will be checkmate that's
why a nice to be for is such a powerful
move but also amongst other things your
it's just an excellent square for the
knight but yeah Andrew didn't go for
that Andrew played with Bishop to e7
attacking the Queen called some
retreated Queen to g3 and repeated
Bishop to d6 calls and repeated Queen to
h4 so basically offering a draw by
threefold repetition but Andrew doesn't
want to draw and rewards to win this he
plays h5 and ok we have King to e1 by
Carlsen and now comes Bishop to see to
win tonight's the before this would
still be winning for black but Andrew
goes for Bishop to see - and here he
allows Carlsen a bit too much time he
does it I mean it's still hard to
believe that white can actually survive
this
but Carson goes Bishop to g2 and now
comes Knight captures on h2 and now it's
not a problem that the knight is
protected by the bishop if you capture
black will not capture the rogue black
left actually capture your queen now
it's checked and you're gonna lose the
Queen on h4 but Knight captures on h2 is
not a losing blunder and Andrews side so
again feel free to pause the video and
find the move that now is winning four
calls and with the white pieces I'll
give you a couple of seconds to do it
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you know you should
definitely check out the Bond cloud and
for those of you who just wanna enjoy
the show
Knight to f4 attacks the Queen and also
prevents this defense of the bishop to
the night and h2 and also prevents the
bishop from coming to g3
so you do have to play something either
you're gonna lose the night you do have
to capture it so but for capture so we
have Queen captures and now what do you
play here and replayed Queen captures
and g2 now comes rook captures on h2
sorry Queen captures on h2 and now Queen
back to e4 Andrew doesn't wanna trade
Queens because now when you count the
pieces Carson is a whole rook up
okay that rook is still on a1 it's not
really part of this game but if he can
develop if he can get all of his pieces
into the game then you know a rock up is
a winning game but okay Queen to e4
Andrew is still very much interested in
checkmate in Carlson Queen captures on
h5 we have looked the g8 and now comes
Queen to h3 going after the e3 e3 pawn
we have King to b8 as the King was in
check and now comes the ship captures on
e3 a very nice idea by Carlsen because
he finds a beautiful sequence we have
looked to e8 here threatening to either
capture the bishop or if the bishop
moves then Queen captures an e 2 will be
checkmate so it's very interesting how
come course and allow do this but it's
not a problem simply nice the c5
attacking the Queen and now if Queen
captures then Queen captures rook
captures and you're not even interested
in winning the bishop would king - C -
you're just gonna checkmate the
King Rock h8 and after black gives all
of the pieces then it will be checkmate
so after night the c5 queen has to go
back we have Queen to g6 and now King to
d2 putting pressure on the bishop will
push it back to f5 attacking the Queen
and now Queen to h5 and here it's very
very hard for blacks to continue this
game if you move the Queen something
like Queen f6 then you're gonna get rook
to f1
so Andrew simply plays b6 make some
escape room for the king
how about also now the Queen's can be
traded off captures captures we have
nice to be 3 and now Carson is up a
whole rook you just have to bring it
into the game a5 and now comes Bishop to
f4 going after the c7 pawn and the rook
h7 is the idea we have a four-night goes
back so for the time being the rook
still is not in the game nice to a5 and
now b3 not allowing night the c4 check
King b7 and now rook to h7 as planned
Brooke the c8 you have to protect the c7
pawn Bishop to e5 King to a6 unpinning
and now comes Luke - b7 not allowing
that a jeep to g7 not allowing the Jeep
on to be pushed
we have c5 Knight the d3 and now pawn
captures on d4 nice to before with check
King moves and only now recapturing on
d5 and we have a cap for son b3 not
first a4 with check King moves the King
can move to other squares let's say c5
but even if you don't blunder this night
to be 6 check white white is still
winning so it's not really that big of a
deal
Queens if a king to c5 with Bishop
captures even grabbing more material
before capturing the rock also the
bishop knob is defending the knight King
moves and now Knight captures on c8 we
have Bishop captures on c8 and now c4
rush up to f5 with King to c3 but there
is very little you can do here you are
down simply too much material
b2 going for the rook but now c5 check
of King moves and now King captures on
b2 we have Knight to c4 with check King
moves and now Knight goes back to the 6
you could have captured the bishop but
being down so much material it's just
the same and
bullet game both players are down to a
couple of seconds you you want to pre
move as much as possible we have King 2
before night Stewie for a rope to d7
check King g6 and after c6 Andrew tank
lost on time in this position but even
if he didn't I mean it's completely
winning you can black completely ignore
whatever black doesn't simply pull the a
point to victory or or whatever but yeah
53 moves you know definitely a nice move
count for who for a bullet game and yeah
I do hope you enjoy that it's I think
it's the first video ever that I've
shown where the bond cloud was played
and I'm not gonna show like more of them
but it is a custom on this channel
whenever there's Elias titled arena for
me to show one game from the winner of
the arena and you can see here I have
this as you can see Carlson won the
tournament
this time he used the nickname everytime
cross and plays elite chess titled arena
he will use a different nickname this
time he was a doctor an actor Stein and
but you can see underneath you have the
points and he only has one point more
than enter tank GM penguin but you know
serves him right for playing for playing
the bong cloud all the time and drinking
beer but yeah you can see that he also
lost four of his games and Andrew was
really on a streak but you know time
time was of the essence Andrew wasn't
simply able to pull it off and in third
place you have an international master
lodewijk Fredrik so definitely an
interesting choice of openings and
definitely winning the delicious titled
arena in great style which this improved
version of the bone cloud so yeah always
interested in your opinion of this have
you ever used the bone cloud in online
chess do you do you think it's it's
useful I've tried a couple of times and
really people will just charge at you
and then they will lose because they
think they can just push over push and
win but usually they can't but yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
have have an excellent rest of the
Sunday I would like to thank you
Julian Boris jung jae-young
Frederico dia Sparta Angelo de Arte and
Keven Prothero for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here think all for watching and I
will see you soon are most likely with
some more games from the London chess
classic and we are starting the
capablanca saga very soon as that series
won the voting contest so thank you all
and I will see you soon